Now that we're back on the reporting pane or view in Power BI,
let's start by just grabbing a single value from our sales transactions.
I'm going to go with amount.
With this single value,
what we're doing is we're summing all the values associated with
this amount in the sales transaction without applying any additional filters or logic.
As you can see, the only thing on the filter pane at this stage is
the amount itself and every time that we add an additional value to a visualization,
that will populate automatically here on the filter pane.
Now, whenever you take a single value and you add it to Power BI,
the default is going to be that it will assume that you want to
use a table and that you want to use Sum.
But as you can see,
there are a number of additional options here,
something that we'll discuss a little bit later as we talk through the implicit measures.
Let's go ahead and add a dimension value to
this small table that we have right here and I'll go ahead and make this a bit bigger.
For our purposes, let's just go ahead and
grab information from the customer data by state.
I'll just go ahead and drag this over to our table and of course I want to
see state before amounts so I'll go head on
the Visualization pane and I will take state and move it above amount.
Now we have values by customer data from this section listing off
the amount for sales functioning as a filter off of that same starting value.
If we take this away, that will still be the single total that we
see but sliced and diced based on the information that we want to include.
We can slice this further,
say if we wanted to see it by zip code as well.